Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Dominar cualquier habilidad física,
ya sea realizar una pirueta,
tocar un instrumento,
o lanzar una pelota de béisbol,
requiere práctica.
La práctica es la repetición de
una acción con el objetivo de mejora,
y ayuda a ejecutar con mayor facilidad,
rapidez y confianza.
¿Qué hace la práctica en nuestro cerebro
para hacernos mejores en las cosas?
Nuestro cerebro tiene
dos tipos de tejido neural:
materia gris
y materia blanca.
La materia gris procesa
la información en el cerebro,
dirige las señales y estímulos
sensoriales a las células nerviosas,
mientras que la materia blanca
se compone sobre todo
de las fibras nerviosas y tejido graso.
Para que nuestros cuerpos se muevan,
la información tiene que viajar
de la materia gris del cerebro,
abajo a la médula espinal,
a través de una cadena de fibras
nerviosas llamadas axones
a nuestros músculos.
¿Cómo la práctica o la repetición
afectan el funcionamiento
interno de nuestro cerebro?
Los axones que existen
en la sustancia blanca
se envuelven con una
sustancia grasa llamada mielina.
Y es esta cubierta de mielina, o vaina,
la que parece cambiar con la práctica.
La mielina es similar al aislamiento
de los cables eléctricos.
Evita la pérdida de energía de las
señales eléctricas que utiliza el cerebro,
moviéndolas de manera más eficiente
a lo largo de las vías nerviosas.
Estudios recientes en ratones sugieren
que la repetición de un movimiento físico
aumenta las capas de la vaina de mielina
que aísla los axones.
Y a más capas, mayor es el aislamiento
alrededor de las cadenas de los axones,
formando una especie de autopista
para la información
que conecta el cerebro a los músculos.
Mientras que muchos atletas y artistas
atribuyen sus éxitos
a la memoria muscular,
los músculos mismos en realidad
no tienen memoria.
Más bien, puede ser la mielinización
de las vías neurales
la que da a estos atletas
y artistas de su ventaja
con vías neurales
más rápidas y eficientes.
Hay muchas teorías que intentan
cuantificar el número de horas,
días e incluso años de práctica
que se necesitan
para dominar una habilidad.
A pesar de que todavía no tenemos
un número mágico,
sabemos que el dominio no se trata
solo de la cantidad de horas de práctica.
Es también la calidad
y eficacia de esa práctica.
La práctica efectiva es consistente,
intensamente centrada
y metas contenidas o debilidades
que se sitúan en el borde
de las habilidades actuales de uno.
Si la práctica efectiva es la clave,
¿cómo podemos obtener el máximo
provecho de nuestro tiempo de práctica?
Prueba estos consejos.
Centrarte en la tarea en cuestión.
Minimiza las distracciones potenciales
apagando la computadora o la televisión
y pon tu teléfono celular en modo avión.
En un estudio, los investigadores
observaron 260 alumnos estudiando.
De media,
los estudiantes solo fueron capaces de
permanecer en la tarea 6 minutos seguidos.
Computadoras portátiles, teléfonos,
y en particular Facebook
fueron la raíz de la mayoría
de las distracciones.
Comience lentamente o en cámara lenta.
La coordinación se construye
con repeticiones,
ya sean correctas o incorrectas.
Si aumentas gradualmente la velocidad
de repeticiones de calidad,
tendrás una mejor oportunidad
de hacerlo correctamente.
Seguir con repeticiones frecuentes
con paradas programadas
son hábitos comunes de práctica
de los atletas de élite.
Los estudios han mostrado que muchos de
los mejores atletas, músicos y bailarines
pasan 50 a 60 horas por semana en las
actividades relacionadas con su oficio.
Muchos dividen su tiempo
de práctica efectiva
en múltiples sesiones de prácticas
diarias de duración limitada.
Y, por último, práctica
en tu cerebro con gran detalle.
Es un poco sorprendente,
pero una serie de estudios sugieren
que una vez que se ha
establecido un movimiento físico,
que puede ser reforzado
con solo imaginarlo.
En un estudio, 144 jugadores de
baloncesto se dividieron en dos grupos.
Un grupo A practicó físicamente
tiros libres con una sola mano
mientras que el Grupo B
solo los practicó mentalmente.
Cuando se midieron al final
de dos semanas de experimento
los jugadores intermedios y
experimentados en los dos grupos
habían mejorado en casi la misma cantidad.
A medida que los científicos desentrañan
los secretos de nuestro cerebro,
nuestra comprensión de
la práctica efectiva solo mejorará.
Mientras tanto, la práctica efectiva
es la mejor manera que tenemos
de empujar nuestros límites individuales,
lograr nuevas alturas,
y maximizar nuestro potencial.